So who's my guest this week?
Dr. Ngozi Okonjo-Iweala.
Harvard, MIT, ex Finance Minister,
so far so predictable.
But this head of the
World Trade Organization
is also breaking down barriers.
The General Council agree to appoint
Dr. Ngozi Okonjo-Iweala of Nigeria
as the next Director General of the WTO.
The first woman, the first African,
and wanting to inject
morality in how we trade.
She's fought corruption
and put her own safety
at risk by doing so.
She's been named one of
the most powerful women
in the world, four years running.
The World Trade Organization.
It made China. China made
themselves, they did a good job.
But they ripped off our country for years.
But can she counter
accusations that the WTO
is in hock to China and
embeds global inequality?
I've got a feeling you're going
to like this conversation.
Here's a taste.
The goal I have is to
make everyone understand,
including the members themselves sometimes
when they forget that
we are here for people.
And when you say people
don't understand the WTO,
do you think the WTO has to
take some of the fault for that?
Well, you're right. I agree with that.
It is the fault that
people don't understand
really what it is and what it does.
Has being a woman helped or hindered
in your political life?
I think it's helped
in the sense that I'm happy to be a woman.
I'm proud of being a woman.
I'm proud of being who I am.
Dr. Ngozi, thank you for joining me.
You have just reached a
year at the helm of the WTO.
I believe you threatened
to walk out last September,
or you could do, you
hadn't bought furniture
in your place in Geneva yet.
What changed?
I think that there was too
much made of what I was saying.
I didn't threaten to walk out.
I told members, indeed I
had not bought furniture,
to spur them on, to try and
negotiate harder, work harder.
For me, this is a job I'm
really passionate about.
So even when I make comments,
it's all geared to getting more
of the work done, getting results.
If you're passionate about
something and you feel
that it's, you're there
to deliver for people.
So I'm impatient for action, for results.
That's what drives me.
Yes, I suppose it was just, if you felt
that the WTO had done a better job
at getting, if you like,
more respected by those
it seems to have lost respect
amongst, not least America.
Well, I don't agree with
the way you characterize it.
It's amazing that even when
you say the organization
has lost respect or is not supported,
one way you can gauge that
is whether members pay their dues.
If you've lost respect for an organization
and you no longer want to be part of it,
you wouldn't support it, would you?
But I'm very proud to say that
including the United States,
all our members are paying up their dues,
they're very supportive.
Yes, we do have some
issues, some challenges.
Joe Biden has just said,
the US continues to
have systematic concerns
with the WTO and at the heart of this,
for those who aren't
that familiar with it,
there's this concern about the requirement
for American workers to compete
against Chinese forced labor,
but not stopping sometimes
the theft of American intellectual
property and products.
It's about how you have made
the playing field unequal.
That's one of the biggest criticisms
that actually Trump, Obama,
and Biden have agreement on.
I think there's a misnomer here.
The WTO does not make the
playing field unequal.
The role is to level the
playing field and to put
rules in place that will ensure
fair trade for everybody.
Now, have those rules been
changed in the past 25 years?
The answer is no.
So obviously some of the agreements
need to be brought up to date.
Some of the rules have to be looked at,
and new rules have to be put in place.
So that is what is the issue here,
but to say that the WTO doesn't serve,
I don't agree with that
because 75% of world trade
still takes place based on WTO rules
and in spite of the hot rhetoric
you hear between countries,
let's say US and China, trade
between the two countries
is still quite robust.
No, but it's, I'm going off the signs
from the leaders of those
countries who actually
have very different political views
but they've all expressed frustration.
And you yourself have just
said, those rules need updating.
So what's the WTO been doing?
What has the WTO been doing?
The WTO has been maintaining
that level playing field
for most of the trade in the world.
As I said, in spite of all the criticism,
75% of world trade still
takes place on the basis
of those rules and if it
didn't exist, like I said
when I was competing for this
job, you'd have to invent it.
So the key issue is how do we make
the reforms that are needed?
Yes, that is my question.
That, sorry, that is at the heart.
No, absolutely.
To point out that there are
challenges, there are reforms,
I myself said that when I
was competing for this job.
So we need to embark on those reforms.
And indeed we are beginning to do that.
Part of the reform is to complete
multilateral negotiations,
which the organization has
not done in a long time.
And that's what we've been pushing for.
We are nearer closer than we've ever been
to completing the fishery
subsidies negotiations.
And I think had it not been
the fact that we postponed
our ministerial meeting from last November
due to Omicron,
we could have been there by now.
So we are regaining momentum,
to try to complete that.
We are also working on the
response to the pandemic.
The WTO has been responsive to an issue
of the global commons
that is facing us now.
We've been working very hard
on several facets of this.
We've been working on supply chain issues
with vaccine manufacturers.
This is where we have a monitoring
and transparency function
that can help producers
look at what is happening
to the supply chains.
So this is very important.
You have huge history and experience
having been chair of
Gavi, the Vaccine Alliance
for a major moment for
the WTO to perhaps improve
the view of it in the eyes of its critics.
Where is the WTO going to come
down on the side of patents
with regards to vaccines
and intellectual property
or lifting them for what's described
as vaccine equity around the world,
because I'm unclear having read into this.
Well, first off all,
let me start by saying
that vaccine inequity is plain wrong.
And we've, I've been very clear on that
as the Director General of the WTO.
Inequity in access doesn't serve anybody,
even those who have been vaccinated,
because it could lead to
more variants multiplying.
Now, the WTO, as I came in, I realized
that several of the functions there
could really be useful in helping
the world to get to a
more equitable situation
with respect to vaccines.
Like I said, people take it for granted,
but the supply chains of
vaccines are very complicated
because they have so many
components, up to 280,
for some of the MRNA vaccines.
If you have an export
restriction of prohibition
on one of those products,
it means the vaccine cannot be produced.
So simply getting our members to reduce
the number of export
restrictions and prohibitions,
which were 119 at the
start of the pandemic,
and we are now down to 35 has helped
to boost production in the world,
helping the producers
monitor the bottlenecks
in their supply chain, raw materials,
and so on has helped them
know what to do with that.
So these kinds of functions
are very important.
Trade facilitation.
We have a trade facilitation agreement
designed to make goods move faster.
And this has been very
helpful to the manufacturers.
We are meeting with the CEOs
of the vaccine manufacturers,
the 10 of them every few
weeks to go over the issue.
That's one side that is often overlooked
because people focus
on the IP and patents,
but to make vaccines, you
need a smooth supply chain.
You need manufacturing capacity,
which we've also been working
with the manufacturers on,
and then you need
technology transfer and IP.
On the IP side, there's been
negotiations as you know at the WTO
that were going on for almost a year
before I came on the scene.
And it's been very
difficult because of course
there are two polarized sides.
Proponents - more than a hundred countries
who want a waiver of the vaccine,
seeing it as being- of the
IP, intellectual property,
seeing it as material to
manufacturing vaccines,
and those who believe that
this could be a detriment
to innovation and to
research and development,
the non-proponents.
Now, what we've tried to do
is to bridge the gap between the two.
We're still working on it.
We're not there yet, but
we're inching forward.
And we have a process going on now.
How you do that when you say
it's two polarized sides like that?
When you talk about bridging the gap,
you are the Director General.
How do you go about doing that?
And do you see an answer soon?
Well, actually the way things work here,
members are supposed to talk to each other
and try to bridge their gaps.
But I've stepped into the process
to try to help that along.
And it's well known, so I can say it,
We're trying to work with
four countries at the moment,
the US, the EU, India, and South Africa
to see if we can come to a framework
which we can then share
with the rest of the
membership fairly quickly
so we can get to agreement on a text
that everybody can support.
It'll be a compromise solution
between the two sides.
So by its nature, a compromise
will not be satisfactory to all sides,
but it is, there's what
we call a landing zone.
It'll be a workable compromise,
and that's what we are aiming for.
What could that look like in the sense of,
will it be that certain vaccines
that the patent is
waived and others aren't?
No, absolutely not.
And I'm afraid, Emma,
that this is one of
the things I cannot do.
We are in the middle
of these negotiations.
So just talking to you about
it, puts it in jeopardy.
So we have to be very sensible.
I cannot go into the details
of what it could look like.
When the agreement is
made, we can talk about it.
I've got to try and get
as much as I can though,
to understand, I suppose,
from your perspective,
how important is this particular
landing zone to get right,
in terms of whether the
WTO should exist at all?
Because there are some
who really don't think
it is fit in its current state.
Well, the WTO, I don't think
we should mix up all sorts of issues.
I've already made it clear
that the WTO is playing a role
that people don't appreciate in the world.
If it didn't exist, there
would really be trouble
in the multilateral trading system.
That's not to say that the
WTO does not have challenges
and has to be made fit for purpose,
but this issue of the IP waiver,
there is a suitable
compromise that would allow
those who want access to be able to meet
some of their needs whilst making sure
that we don't disincentivize
research and innovation,
which is what the non-proponents want.
So that's the kind of middle
ground we're looking for.
So nobody will have
100% of what they want,
but there'll be a workable solution
that both sides can live with.
And the workable solution
to, I don't know,
a farmer in America, who's lost his job
because of unfair competition with China.
What's a workable solution that the WTO
comes for him or her?
If they're thinking well,
I'm not sure America
should pay their dues to an organization
that has still failed to reform
trading practices between
two giant members?
Let me repeat one thing.
WTO is a member-driven organization.
So the members need to talk
to each other and negotiate.
It provides a negotiating forum.
So for them to approach each
other, talk to each other,
to try and resolve these issues.
That being said, there
are certain agreements
that have been in place at the WTO,
which if we renew or revamp could help
with some of these issues.
But first we have to get our facts right.
Because a farmer has,
or somebody working in a
coal mine has lost their job.
We really need to look at
the factors behind that.
It's sometimes lazy thinking
to just blame trade.
Sometimes it's technology
that is the cause of that displacement.
And you need governments to implement
active labor market policies to solve it.
Sorry, but if I may,
political leaders and I named
three American presidents
who are not aligned always,
it's fair to say politically,
have all said, if I say
the Trump Administration
accused the WTO of being
completely inadequate
and Joe Biden to repeat says
the US has systematic concerns.
And we've also seen you
talk about paying your dues,
that's one indicator if a country's happy,
but it's now an not going
to, the Biden Administration
is not going to appoint
new members to the panel
who look at trade disputes with the WTO.
What I'm trying to say is
there is a narrative here
where in one hand you say,
it's a member organization,
they've got to talk to each other,
but you are receiving millions
and millions of pounds
and dollars to help countries do
what they can't do their own.
So you can't say it's up to countries
and then still have this arbitration role.
No, you, I think people
don't understand the WTO.
The WTO is a member organization
that has a secretariat
that supports members
to get these negotiations done.
So there is no kind of
WTO sitting out there,
it's the members are the WTO.
Hang on, sorry, are you saying Joe Biden
doesn't understand the WTO
'cause I'm taking my lead
from the president of America.
No, I'm saying that the way
you're characterizing it
is not the way it is.
Let tell you what people
are frustrated at.
If members have not been
able to talk to each other
with the support of the secretariat
to solve some of these problems,
of course there's frustration.
And it is true that the US,
said they don't like what goes on
with the dispute settlement system.
And that the way the system
runs the appellate body
has overreached in terms of
the way it makes judgments.
That has been a complaint
over many administrations.
And what's the answer to that?
The answer is that we should reform it,
which is what we're presently discussing.
One of the things we want to make sure
we table at our 12th Ministerial,
which is now going to be on June 13,
is how do we indeed reform,
do the fundamental reforms of the WTO?
How do we rework the
dispute settlement mechanism
so that it can serve all the
members the way they want?
If I may there is presently
a dispute in the WTO
amongst the members about
how to handle disputes?
Yes.
Right.
Okay, and when you say-
That is true,
When you say people
don't understand the WTO,
do you think the WTO has to
take some of the fault for that?
That it's this organization
that isn't well understood
around the world and people don't think
it provides value for money sometimes?
Well you are right. I agree with that.
And that is, I think it is the fault
that people don't understand really
what it is and what it does.
And it's mischaracterized.
Including the president of America?
I'm not saying that, I don't
want words put in my mouth.
I think the president is not satisfied
with the way the organization is working
because they're not happy
with the dispute settlement mechanism,
and some of their
complaints are well founded.
That's why we need to reform
the dispute settlement system.
But to reform it is those same members
that have to sit around the table,
there is no rescuer coming from outside.
You've not got an easy job, have you?
You really don't-
The US and all the others
have to sit around the table
and agree on how they're
going to make these reforms,
be it dispute settlement, be
it the monitoring function.
Now, all I can tell you is that as the DG,
we try to support them to do that.
And now we are looking at the reform
of the WTO's core functions
as one of the big subjects
that we're going to look
at at the 12th Ministerial.
So we will start the discussion
and the debate there,
and then they will agree eventually
on how they want to move this forward.
What gets you out of bed in the morning?
What motivates you?
You could have been having-
I think I have one of the most
interesting jobs in the world,
that's why I applied for it.
Let me tell you something, this WTO,
the purpose of this was
inscribed in the charter
when it was created in 1994
in the preamble to the
Marrakesh Agreement.
And it says that the WTO's purpose
is to enhance living standards,
to help create employment and to support
sustainable development.
In other words, it's all about people,
and that's what drives me.
And the goal I have is to
make everyone understand,
including the members themselves,
sometimes when they forget
that we are here for people.
You are right.
The ordinary person on the
street in my village in Nigeria
needs to know why the WTO exists
and what it exists for, because it's doing
some very, very important and good things.
So that's what drives me.
I get up in the morning,
ready, raring to go to work
because I want us to deliver for people.
The Fisheries Subsidies
Agreement, let me just take that.
There are 260 million people that depend
on fisheries in the world.
If we're able to conclude that deal,
we will stop overcapacity and overfishing,
which is now almost at 50%.
And that will secure the
livelihoods of so many people.
When we get to the
response to this pandemic,
and we have a package
agreed by all members,
we have been contributing
already very materially
to solving the issue of
vaccines, production, and access,
which I'm very proud about.
And that is something
that delivers for people.
So that's what I want to everyone to know.
The WTO is about people.
You have been credited in your time
in politics in Nigeria,
which you've just mentioned
with saving a lot of
money for the country.
You're in fact nicknamed
the $9 billion woman
for making sure that you
could try and face down
as much corruption as possible.
What is it about you and
your style, do you think,
that you hope helps people get
to more agreement, to a better place?
Well, I think it's
because I never give up.
I'm an optimist by nature.
I am very enthus-
I never take on a job unless
I'm passionate about it.
So I get up every morning wanting to go,
and I think people see that.
They also see that no matter
how difficult the situation is,
I will not give up.
I will work as hard as
possible to push for results.
I'm very results-oriented
and that's what is attractive at the WTO.
We can achieve results
that will benefit people.
So people see that,
and I think they can
relate to the sincerity
that I have for the job.
Has being a woman helped or hindered
in your political life?
I think it's helped in the sense
that I'm happy to be a woman.
I'm proud of being a woman.
I'm proud of being who
I am from where I am.
So when you have that self
confidence, it helps you to lead.
Of course, when you are a woman
and I've written a book
about it with Julia Gillard,
the former Prime Minister of Australia,
which is quite popular.
Now it's called Women and Leadership:
Real Lives, Real Lessons.
And we look at eight women
leaders and at ourselves,
you will see that when
you're a woman in leadership,
there are a number of challenges
that confront you along the way
from looking at how you handle issues.
You cannot be too soft because people
will then criticize
you for being too soft,
but you can't be too strident
because then they think
you're very aggressive.
So women leaders we found are
always watching their style
to make sure that they balance it out.
But at the end of the day,
what most of the women
in leadership have found
is that you just have to be yourself.
You lead best when you are yourself,
because you're authentic
and you don't have to
try and be anyone else.
So of course there've been
challenges along the way.
If you're a woman of color,
there are even more
challenges along the way.
When I walk into a room,
people are surprised
when they see the way I'm dressed,
which is the way I've always dressed.
And you can see some assumptions
on the faces of some of the people,
because they look at your appearance
and make some judgements.
Maybe this person cannot
handle the job or whatever,
but the minute I open my mouth
and talk about the substance,
people forget that.
So I don't spend time dwelling
on whether I'm a woman
or a woman of color.
I dwell on what do I bring to the job
and how is my knowledge helping
to change things in the place?
And that's what excites me.
I think when people see you
have what it takes to run,
they relate to it.
I've been a manager for instance,
for a long time in my
career at The World Bank,
which is a huge organization.
I've been Minister of Finance
with thousands of people
under my, in my ministry.
So I have experience.
So when I come to a job at the WTO,
I try to put that experience
to the benefit of the organization.
And what I can say is I'm,
I love the job.
I have to be very honest,
but I also have to be honest
that I do get irritated
when we don't move
quickly towards results.
Maybe that's what, the only aspect.
But I use my experience to
try and make things work.
Have you bought any furniture yet?
Oh yeah, it's too late now.
Dr. Ngozi, thank you very much indeed
for your time and your experience.
Thank you, Emma.
Thank you so much for being with us.
Until we meet again,
stay safe and goodbye.